- I say in the book, when
I walked in that room,
I knew 15 of the other 16 Republicans
who were running for president.
I mean, I knew Marco
Rubio, I know John Kasich,
I knew Jeb Bush, I had met them all.
The only one I had never
met was Donald Trump,
so I was kinda curious.
And I say in the book,
when I walked in that room,
I did not like him, I
did not like his persona,
I thought he was kind of a blowhard.
I thought his run for presidency
was a publicity stunt, frankly.
And we spent about an hour
and 20 minutes with him,
and I walked out with stars in my eyes.
(intense music)
- I'm Dave Rubin, and
this the "Rubin Report."
Quick reminder to subscribe and make sure
that you get notified of our videos.
Why not, right?
Okay, joining me today
is an author, economist,
and former advisor to President Trump.
Steve Moore, welcome
to the "Rubin Report."
- Hi, Dave, thanks for having me.
- I am glad to have you here.
We're gonna have to talk somewhat quick
because you're in a
major time crunch here.
- It's an honor to be on the show.
- I'm thrilled to have you here.
This is gonna be a little
quicker than my average show,
so I usually do a little--
- Rapid fire, all right.
- I do a little backstory usually.
I try to find out where people are from
and all sorts of stuff.
We're gonna do that next
time I sit down with you.
Let's go right into economics.
As a "Wall Street Journal"
guy and a longtime economist,
and you studied at George
Mason, and all of this stuff,
how would you say your...
what would you say your
economic principles are?
Let's just do 101, Moore economics.
- Well, I believe in
freedom and free markets.
I believe that as Thomas Jefferson said,
that government which least governs best,
and get the government for the most part
out of the way of the economy,
and it'll do just fine.
That's not to say we
shouldn't have regulation.
We should certainly have smart...
We want clean air and clean
water and safe workplaces.
We wanna a tax system
that raises the revenue
the government needs, but in a
way that is non-confiscatory.
Are you listening, Elizabeth Warren?
- (laughs) We'll talk
about her in a little bit.
- And it doesn't distort the economy.
So I've been a flat tax
guy for all my life.
I love the idea, let's just
have a really low rate,
everybody pays it.
You make 10 times more money than I do,
you pay 10 times more tax,
and not 50 times more tax,
and get rid of all the
loopholes in the tax system.
So I believe the free enterprise system
is the goose that lays the golden eggs.
- All right, so I'm basically
with you on all of that,
but let's do the flat tax for a second.
So I would be basically for something
like 15% for everybody.
Would you do something to help the people
that are at the lowest--
- Yes.
- So a certain amount of
people would pay nothing.
- Yeah, so like in the
standard flat tax plan,
you said 15%, I'd love that,
but most plans are about 18%,
and then you basically
say for a family of four,
roughly your first say
$30,000 earned is tax free,
and then above that amount, you pay a tax.
So people below the poverty line
are not paying any federal income tax.
I think most people regard
that as fair and equitable
and very pro-growth and
would love to see it.
The reason it doesn't happen
is not even because liberals oppose it,
it's the special interest
groups in Washington.
Do you think they wanna a flat tax?
- The lobbyists make money
buying and selling favors in the tax code.
If you have a flat tax, what
do they have to sell and buy?
- No more favors.
- If you really wanna drain
the swamp, go to a flat tax.
- Would you do anything on
the really high side of that?
(laughing)
- So right now, you
mentioned Elizabeth Warren.
- We'd be good at 19%.
- Is there something you would do,
even if it didn't work sort
of economically in your mind,
just to kinda throw the
progressives a bone?
- You know why I don't like it?
I get it, I get asked that question a lot.
You know why I don't like that?
'Cause you say, "Well,
why don't we just have 20%
"for the really rich?"
And then Elizabeth Warren
says, "What about 25?
"Why not 30, why not..."
We had tax rates at one
point in this country at 91%.
So I don't like that idea,
'cause I think it perverts the...
I love the idea everybody
pays the same rate.
No, the idea, oh, we're
just gonna have a surcharge
on the Bill Gates and the
Warren Buffets of the world,
they will pay their tax.
When they earn their
money, they will pay it.
And by the way, those
are people who employ
in some cases hundreds
of thousands of workers.
They pay tax, so I wanna retain
the virtue and simplicity
of a one-rate system.
- Right, those guys are also
always for raising taxes,
and yet they don't voluntarily pay more.
- Yeah, isn't that interesting?
- What do you make of the
mind of someone like that?
- Well, there's a group called
the Patriotic Millionaires.
There's something like 100
millionaires and billionaires
who have signed something
saying, "We wanna pay more tax."
I call them the hypocritical millionaires
because there's nothing
to prevent somebody...
At the bottom line of your tax form is
if you wanna pay more
money into the Treasury,
you can write a check,
and none of them do that.
So my feeling is that
they want other people
to pay more tax, but they don't
wanna pay more themselves.
And then they say, "Well, but
the tax system's involuntary,"
and I'm like, wait a minute,
you know people voluntarily wanna serve,
people sign up for the military.
Those are patriotic people,
they care about our country,
and they're willing to give
potentially their life for our country.
But these quote, "patriotic
millionaires" won't pay
more tax themselves, but
they want other people
to pay more tax.
- Does it become one of those odd things
where it's like the CEO
of Walmart or something
will publicly say that he's
for a $15 minimum wage,
where he knows actually it
won't ultimately hurt him,
but it'll hurt--
- That's a great point.
- All the small businesses that
won't be able to afford it.
He'll be able to afford it.
- Oh, yeah.
That's why a lot of the
regulations in Washington
that liberals want,
they are able to team up
with the big companies,
because the big companies
can absorb the cost
of requiring a company to
pay healthcare benefits
or education benefits or
raise the minimum wage,
so it's a way actually of
strengthening the big guys
and strangling the small guys
who are trying to compete
with the big guys.
The small businesses are the
ones who get hurt the most
by those kinds of regulations.
- Right, it's interesting
that you mentioned
in relation to tax that even
if you threw somebody a bone,
it's never enough kind of,
which reminds me of the
$15 minimum wage thing,
where Rashida Tliab said,
"Well, why not $20?"
And then it's like, well, Bernie or Warren
or the rest of them, they have
nothing to really stand on
to say why it should be 15 and not 20,
'cause once you artificially
put these numbers in--
- By the way, I'm for the highest wages
Americans can possibly get.
- So how do you ensure that then
without doing too much
government involvement?
- Well, you don't have to
have the government do it.
First of all, one of the principles,
you asked me about
principles of economics,
one good principle is you
never want the government
setting prices or setting wages.
That's supposed to be done by
the free enterprise system,
the law of supply and demand.
And when you have the
government come in and set...
I'll give you an example in a sec.
You are living here in Los Angeles.
In a lotta cities, you have rent control
to try to make housing more
affordable for poor people.
Look, we all want people to have shelter
and a roof over their head.
But it turns out, this
is an perfect example
of the law of unintended consequences.
It turns out when you
actually impose rent control,
you actually reduce the
amount of affordable housing
and you actually have more
people homeless, not less.
And New York City found that,
and yet liberals seem to
never understand that,
and it's the same thing with,
what were you asking me about, the--
- Well, the minimum wage.
- Yeah, the minimum wage.
- It's like it's not
hinged to reality sort of,
so once someone says it should be 15,
well, then why not 20,
and then why not 25?
- Yeah, exactly, and
so what tends to happen
when you raise the minimum
wage is you actually,
the people who tend to get hurt the most
are the people with the least skill,
because you essentially
price them outta the market.
I always tell the story,
I have two teenage sons,
I love them to death, but I'd
never pay them $15 an hour,
right?
- Right.
- I mean, they don't have
the training and skills
to warrant a $15 a hour wage.
Why not, especially for young people,
let them work for $7 or $8
an hour and gain the skills.
I remember very well, by
the way, my first job.
I think most people listening to this,
watching the show, remember.
Do you remember the first job you ever had
where you got a paycheck?
- I do.
- What was that?
- I was a paperboy.
- A paperboy, okay.
- I was working in a small warehouse
in Northbrook, Illinois.
But you learn a lot with your first job,
how to show up on time, how
to be nice to be your boss,
how to learn some skills,
so you learn that whether
you're delivering newspapers
or whether you're working in a factory.
So I don't like that about it.
I like letting the wages rise,
and that's happened
under Trump, by the way.
We've gotten really nice
wage gains under Trump
through the free enterprise system
in creating a very tight labor market.
Workers have a lot of
bargaining power right now.
- So you advised Trump on the tax cuts
a couple of years ago.
Talk to me just a little
bit about what's that like,
when you're sitting in
a room with this guy?
Are his guiding principles
sort of economically
what you've kinda laid out?
He's obviously a capitalist.
- Do you know Trump?
- I've never met him personally.
- So he's a really good guy.
Believe it or not, I
always say half-jokingly
that most politicians are
wonderful people in public
and jerks in private.
Trump can be a jerk in public,
but he is a wonderful person in private.
I like him a lot.
He's interesting, he's charming,
he's attentive to what you're saying.
He looks at you straight in the eye
and he wants to know,
and he'll combat you.
I like that, he'll joust with you
if he doesn't agree with your position,
which he'll have four or
five people in the room
and they'll argue, and that's
what good CEO should do,
not just surround themselves with yes men,
but people who will argue out the point.
- So when you guys sat
down and he's going,
"I wanna cut taxes and this is
one of the things I promised.
"Now help me pull this thing together."
What's that like?
- I'll give you one example.
This tells you a lot about the tax bill,
but it also tells you about Donald Trump.
So I remember we went into
Trump, this was Larry Kudlow,
and now Larry's now the chief economist,
and we said, "Hey," we
showed him this chart
that had the U.S. tax rate
on our businesses was 40%
and the rest of the world
was on average about 20%.
And we said, "You know,
this is a problem for us."
As Larry called it, it's a 20% headstart
for all the countries we're competing with
'cause they've got a lower
penalty that they face.
As a result of that,
companies were leaving
the United States and
they were going to Ireland
or they were going to Canada
or they were going to Mexico.
This was called inversions,
it's where companies were giving up
their American citizenship
to move somewhere else.
So anyway, we said to Trump,
"We think you should have a
20% rate in your tax plan."
And I'll never forget,
he sat back and he said,
"No, I'm not gonna do that."
We said, "Well, why?"
He said, "I want 15%."
And what was so interesting about that
was that from that moment
until we passed the bill
in late December of 2017,
he always insisted on 15%,
whether it's a meeting
with Mitch McConnell
or Paul Ryan or any public
declaration, 15, 15, 15.
And I'll never forget, we were waiting
for the final vote in the Senate,
'cause we needed to get 50 votes
in the Senate to pass this,
we were nervous about
whether we could this.
Remember, on Obamacare,
we came up with 49 votes,
one vote short, so we didn't
wanna come up with 49 again.
So we're very nervous,
we're waiting for McConnell
to come back from his come-to-Jesus moment
when they had their final meeting
in the Senate Republican caucus
to see if they had 50 votes.
And I remember he walks in,
he goes right up to the
president, and he said,
"Mr. President, I'm so
sorry, I failed you.
"I know you wanted that 15% tax rate.
"I made every argument I possibly could,
"and I failed you, Mr. President.
"What can I say?
"I just couldn't convince my colleagues.
"I said I couldn't get you that 15%."
He said, "Would you take 20%."
Well, Trump went, "Yeah,
I'll take that in a minute."
I really believe the
really interesting thing
about that story is I always thank God,
"Thank you, God, that Donald Trump
"didn't listen to Larry and I."
He does understand the art of the deal.
I think he wanted 20% all along,
but he understood if
you wanna end up at 20%,
that's not your opening bid, right?
So he started at 15, and I guarantee you,
I guarantee you if he had started at 20%
like Larry and I had,
we would have ended up
at about 27 or 28%.
It's because he started at 15,
the negotiated position was 20.
Well, we ended up actually at
21%, but that's pretty good.
- Do you think basically
that is his secret sauce to everything?
I mean, we could even take this
outside of the world of economics,
just that negotiating
like that is basically,
that is his greatest skill, period.
- Well, you know the
name of his book, right?
- "The Art of the Deal."
He's a good negotiator, he is.
I've seen him many times in person
and he knows how to negotiate.
That's what's made him
successful in business.
Look, he's made mistakes as president.
I'm not an apologist for Trump.
I like where we are with the economy,
but yeah, I think this
is one of his assets,
he's a very good negotiator.
- So where are we exactly
right now with the economy?
- Good, it's good.
- Depending on who you listen to,
it seems like we're all over the place.
- Well, first of all, let me say this.
If I had told you three years ago
that after say three years of Trump,
not quite three, but we're good,
we would have the lowest
unemployment rate in 50 years,
the lowest inflation rate in 50 years,
the lowest interest rates in 50 years,
and the biggest wage gains in 30 years,
that's a pretty darn good economy,
and that's what we have right now.
We have 7.1 million surplus
jobs in the United States.
Think about that.
That's never happened before
in the history of our country.
7.1 million unfilled jobs,
that's larger than the entire population
of the state of Indiana.
That's how many surplus jobs.
What that means is workers
have bargaining power.
It goes back to what
we were saying before.
So you don't like your
job working for Joe's,
you can go down the
street and work for Susan
and she's gonna give you a higher offer.
We just had negotiations
between the UAW and GM.
The UAW, it looks like
they've gotten pretty much
what they wanted in
these negotiations, why?
Because it's not like UAW
can go find other workers,
there's a shortage of them.
So I think it's been a
positive thing for workers.
Let me summarize, if you
are an American worker
and you are looking for a job,
and you have some kind of useful skill,
this is the best labor market
in any of our lifetimes.
It's really good.
Can it continue?
I think it can.
- So you mentioned regulation before,
how do you figure out
where the moments are
that you have to use
the touch of government,
because as you said, you are
for some level of regulation?
- The way I like to put it is,
look, we all believe in, not
all of us, but most of us--
(laughing)
Be careful.
- In sound regulation
that makes the economy
run and stops cheaters
and things like that.
- I have a lot of Libertarians
that watch this show though.
- There's some who want no regulation.
- Just by saying the word regulation,
a lot of them--
- I have friends
who don't even believe
you should have to drive
on the right side of the road.
(laughing)
Good luck.
My point is that I believe regulations
should be guardrails on the road,
so to keep you on the road.
The left believes that
a lot of the regulations
should be roadblocks to
prevent people from...
We want our businesses to succeed,
but we wanna them to stay
on the straight and narrow.
Too many times, I saw this
in the Obama administration,
too many times the regulations
were just meant to bring these
companies to an abrupt stop,
and I think that's the difference.
We want regulation that makes
sense, that's cost effective,
and that achieves its mission
without disrupting our economy
in a way that will destroy jobs.
- Can you give me an
example of a regulation
that Trump has cut?
There was the original, wasn't
there that idea at one point
that for every new
regulation he was gonna pass,
he was gonna cut something,
like 70 regulations?
- Two, he said, "I want every
new one, we get rid of two,"
and actually so far for every new one,
we've kinda removed 20.
So he's been a big deregulator.
- So can you give me an example
of where something like that
that he's cut has actually
helped the economy?
- Well, the best example
is in the energy area.
Barack Obama and his team
hated the fossil fuel industry.
They hated shale, oil, and gas.
They hated the coal producers.
So they passed regulations that were,
by the way, the law says that
regulations should be passed
in a way where they're
achievable for an industry.
In other words, they shouldn't be designed
to bankrupt a company.
- To take out an industry.
- But in the area of coal,
the intention was precisely
to just put the coal
producers outta business,
and it hurt our own gas.
Now we've got a situation
where we're producing
more oil and gas and
coal than ever before,
we're producing more nuclear power,
and that's created for
the first time in our,
again, in your or my lifetime,
we're actually producing
more oil and gas than we're consuming.
I mean, that's a pretty
cool thing to think about.
We're no longer susceptible
to Arab oil embargoes
or the Russian influence.
You saw what happened when the Iranians
bombed the oil fields in Saudi Arabia.
That was, what, about
three or four weeks ago.
If that had happened
before the shale revolution
that we have going on,
the price of gasoline...
Well, what are you paying
here in California?
You pay a lot for gas.
- I don't even know what it is.
I have an electric car now,
so I'm not so sure.
- It's like 4 or $5 a gallon.
But on the East Coast, where I live,
you pay maybe $3 a gallon.
The price of gas would probably have gone
to about $6 a gallon if it
hadn't been for the fact
that the United States
is actually now producing
a lot of oil and gas ourselves.
- So do you think that the
primary role of the government
basically is to make sure that
the economy is running right?
Is that really the first thing
that the government has to do?
- It's to protect our life
and our liberty, and
the reason we have laws
is to make sure that I
don't violate your rights
and you don't violate my rights.
I'm kind of old-fashioned, I
believe if I'm doing something
that doesn't interfere with
your rights to life and liberty,
that you should be able to do it.
I don't like laws that
are intended, for example,
to protect me from myself.
I think adults should be
able to do pretty much...
I don't like drugs, I don't like tobacco,
I don't smoke, I don't do drugs.
But if you wanna do drugs, I
think you're stupid to do them.
- No comment, no comment.
(laughing)
But I don't think the
government should be involved
in those kind of decisions.
- What else should we know about Trump
as someone that has
spent some time with him?
Not even the negotiating part,
I mean, to give us a little insight
into just the human part.
But it's a little hard
to just figure it out
through the media.
- One of the things that
impressed me the most
when I wrote the book, "Trumponomics"
with my friend, Art Laffer,
the first few chapters that
I recommend people read
are just if they're interested
in how Trump operates
is to read those, because
we really talk about
how Trump just as a
person, what's he like.
One of the things that first impressed me
when we were called by Corey Lewandowski
was running the campaign back then,
and will go down in the history books
for getting Trump through
that Republican nomination,
Trump called us in something
like January of 2016
and said, "Mr. Trump
would like to meet you
"and Larry Kudlow at Trump Tower."
So I was curious.
The Trump movement was
just sort of getting going
at that point, but you could
sense something was going on,
and I wanted to see what it was all about.
I say in the book, when
I walked in that room,
I knew 15 of the other 16 Republicans
that were running for president.
I knew Marco Rubio, I know John Kasich,
I knew Jeb Bush, I had met them all.
The only one I had never
met was Donald Trump,
so I was kinda curious.
And I say in the book,
when I walked in that room,
I did not like him, I
did not like his persona,
I thought he was kind of a blowhard.
I thought his run for presidency
was a publicity stunt, frankly.
And we spent about an hour
and 20 minutes with him,
and I walked out with stars in my eyes.
He's an incredibly charming
and charismatic person,
and he's always personally
been very good to me.
He doesn't throw people under
the bus that are loyal to him,
and I've tried to be loyal to
him, and it goes both ways.
When I went through the
fed reserve nomination
and just got pulverized by all
these accusations against me,
I remember I would call Trump up,
call the president and say,
"Mr. President, if this
is a problem for you,
"that I hate black
people and I hate midgets
"and I hate Jews, and
all these allegations,"
and I said, "Look, if this is a problem,
"I'm happy to step down."
- You do realize that that's the clip
that people are gonna put online.
(laughing)
- Yeah, I know, but let
me be very clear, folks,
I don't hate Jews, I don't hate blacks,
I don't hate midgets.
I'm saying that's the kind of thing
they were saying about me.
But anyway, I said, "Mr. President,
"if that's a problem for you,
"I don't wanna embarrass you."
He said, he was, "Get back
there, keep fighting."
And one thing I do respect about Trump,
and look, a lot of the
things he does and says,
I don't like at all.
I wish he would stop
tweeting, for example.
But what I went through was
for about three or four weeks
of just getting pulverized in the media.
Finally, my wife said,
"If you stay in this,
"I'm gonna divorce you."
- Wow.
(laughing)
- And so I just said, okay,
I can't take this anymore.
Trump has taken 1,000 times what I took,
and day after day after day after day,
and yet he never lets...
It just wore me down,
but he doesn't get down.
- How do you think he does that?
- He's like a superhero (laughs)
or something in the sense.
It's like he's got a coat
of armor or something
that protects him from
these insults and stuff.
He's always called a racist,
and that's the other thing I found.
I couldn't believe how
many blacks and minorities
he had working for him,
and they loved him.
So he's not a perfect person by any means,
he's got a lot of faults,
but I think he's a...
The one thing you always
ask me, what drives him?
And it really is, how do we
make America great again,
and how do we make sure
that the economy is working
for middle class blue-collar workers?
'Cause those are the
people who elected Trump.
Those were the people
in Erie, Pennsylvania,
and Lansing, Michigan,
and Oshkosh, Wisconsin,
and Charleston, West Virginia,
who frankly were pissed
off at both parties,
Democrats and Republicans.
They didn't like the Bush years,
they didn't like the Obama years.
And Trump knows the people
who brought him to this dance.
- Do you think there's any risk
in having a sorta pure businessman
as the chief executive?
- I think it's a breath of fresh air.
I think that's the reason he won.
I think people were sick of politicians.
Remember, what was his closing
argument in the election?
Do you remember the campaign?
- Well, there were a couple of things.
One of them is what do you have to lose?
(laughing)
- Yeah, that one was good.
- That was one of the big ones.
- The other one was, drain the swamp.
And I gotta tell you, that
really appealed to people
around the country because Washington,
this is one of my little pet peeves
and Trump tapped into this,
Washington is getting rich at
the expense of the rest of us.
Three of the five wealthiest
counties in the United States
are in or around Washington,
did you know that?
- Yeah.
- Three of the five, how did we do that?
I've lived in Washington for 30 years.
We don't produce anything.
All we produce is laws,
learners, politicians,
rules, regulations, and we're getting rich
at the expense of the rest of the country.
And you know what?
The American people finally caught on.
It's like, wait a minute,
we're sending all our money to Washington,
we send them a trillion dollars,
they send us $900 billion back,
and they keep the rest of the money.
And I think that's something
that I really admire about Trump.
He is trying to drain the swamp.
But boy, is that tough to do.
- Okay, so some of the
principles you laid out here
strike me as a lotta common sense stuff,
and I definitely fall in line with that.
When you now hear the ideas of socialism
being thrown around as if
this is the right set of ideas
or when you listen to say
Bernie or Elizabeth Warren,
and the amount of government
involvement they want to use
to create their perfect utopian society,
are you shocked that these
ideas gained traction?
- I am, I don't think shocked
would be the term I'd use, I'm distressed.
I'm lucky enough to have been
friends with Milton Friedman,
who is maybe the greatest
economist for the last 200 years,
at least since Adam Smith,
and he was just a wise man
in so many things.
- I was on the front page
of the New York Times in
a compilation with him
as some of the leaders of the far right.
- Wow.
- That's how bananas
the media is.
- So cool.
- So I'm sympathetic to
your wife's situation.
- An amazing guy, and I remember
towards the end of his life
which was around the turn of the century,
he died in the early 2000s, he said to me,
and it was kind of in despair, he said,
"Steve, what is the most enduring lesson
"of the 20th century?"
I think we both agreed, I
think most people would agree,
the enduring lesson of the 20th century
is that communism,
socialism, Nazism, Maoism,
Bernie Sanders-ism, whatever
you wanna call these things,
these government controls of
the economy, they're a failure.
And the free enterprise
system is a success.
That's what everybody should have learned
over the last 100 years.
It's how the United States of America
became the most economically
powerful nation in the world.
And then he said, "But
yet the lesson everyone
"seems to have learned is
we need more socialism."
(laughing)
So it is disturbing, we
have overwhelming evidence--
- Do you think that's just lazy thinking?
What do you think that is?
Is it a branding of capitalism
that's wrong.
- Yes.
- Have we grown fat on all of the excesses
because it's so freaking great.
- Yes, I think both of those things.
You make two great points.
Number one, capitalism, I don't really use
the term capitalism anymore
because it's seen as greed
and the rich getting richer,
so I think we've lost that term.
I talk about free enterprise system
and let people start businesses,
let people do what they wanna do,
let the economy work itself out.
The other point you make is I do think
we've become fat and happy,
and especially the millennials
who, you've seen these polls,
52% of college graduates
now think that socialism
is superior to free market capitalism.
I mean, how stupid is
that, to believe that?
Now part of that is the schools.
We've done a horrible
job of allowing the left
to take over our government school system,
and now we're paying
a high price for that.
We're turning out kids who don't know
anything about anything.
It's a big task we have at hand.
One other thing, I don't even think
we should call them socialists.
People like Elizabeth Warren
and Bernie Sanders are authoritarians.
You were saying that you
have Libertarian tendencies
and I do, too.
I don't want the government
to tell me what to do.
- That's it.
- They do want the government,
they want the government to tell you
what kind of straw you can use,
what kind of light bulb
you can use in your home,
where you have to set your thermostat at,
what kind of car you can drive--
What kind of school you can go to.
- What kind of school, I
mean, they want control
of everything, and when
I talk to young people,
this is my plea, I'm
so glad to do this show
'cause I know you've got a great audience,
for young people watching this show,
freedom and liberty are
precious commodities.
Most people in the world don't have
the freedoms and liberties
that you and I have
or the people watching the show.
Guard those jealously.
Millions of Americans
have given up their lives
to safeguard those freedoms and liberties.
And now we've got a whole
generation of kids who's willing
to just throw those
liberties and freedoms away.
It distresses me.
- Well, one of the
things that I always find
so confusing about it is that
the arguments run so thin.
So just in the last couple of weeks,
AOC was giving a speech
about how she didn't want
Mark Zuckerberg to be in
charge of her healthcare.
- (laughing) Exactly.
- Now I get it, I don't
really want Mark Zuckerberg
to be in charge of my healthcare.
I don't know exactly
why she was saying that,
but it's like, well, what she wants
is Bernie to be in charge
of your healthcare.
And I don't know, who's
worse outta those two?
- You know who should be in
charge of your healthcare?
- You!
- You, exactly.
We should all be.
This is the danger, I
mean, think about this.
The two industries, I talk about this
in every speech I give,
what two industries in America
are most dominated by government?
- Healthcare and--
- And education.
- And education, okay.
- Yeah.
These are the two industries
we've basically turned
over to the government.
Look, our healthcare system
is 50% private and 50% government.
- And now the progressives
don't want school choice either,
which is completely insane.
- Of course.
So think about this though,
so you got the two industries
that are most run by government,
guess which two industries
have had the biggest increase
in cost over the last 50 years?
Education and healthcare.
- I think I'm with you here.
- You don't have to be a genius here.
So wait a minute, and then
I ask my liberal friends,
"Why do we have the government
play such a big role
"in education and healthcare?"
You know what they say?
"To make it more affordable."
Gee, they're doing a wonderful
job with it, aren't they?
So why not let every kid,
you and I have to start a movement,
every child in America,
whether they're black, brown,
whatever color, whatever income
range, wherever they live,
it is a disgrace that we're
sending millions of kids
to failing schools.
Why not allow every single
American to have the right
that Barack Obama had when
he moved to Washington, D.C.
and moved into public housing,
right, in the White House?
What did he do?
He didn't send his kids
to the public schools.
He sent them to elite private schools.
Why can't we let every single
American have that same right
and have the schools compete for kids?
Competition is a wonderful thing.
- Literally just this morning,
we're gonna hold this
video for a couple of days,
but I just saw Elizabeth
Warren tweet this morning
about how she basically wants
to take out charter schools.
- She did?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Oh my god, that is so distressing.
- I just retweeted it this morning.
- It's like they wanna force people...
This gets to the whole idea
you and I were just talking about.
Who can make a better
decision about what schools
their kids should go to,
Elizabeth Warren or the
parents of those kids?
Who do you think cares
more about those kids?
- To give the devil his due here,
what do you think the root of
what these people think is?
So okay, we can sit here and agree
that their ideas are bad, let's say,
but they obviously don't believe that.
- I think they have a trust in government.
- They just have a fundamental
trust in something else.
- Well, look, I think there's
a sinister answer to that
and then I do think some just
believe government is good,
and all we need is just
to spend more money
on the public schools.
That's all we've been
doing for the last 50 years
and they're getting worse, not better.
So my attitude is just from,
I don't care what your
political philosophy is,
if you keep doing something over and over,
and it doesn't work, you
stop doing it, right?
But the other thing is,
let's be honest about this.
Who runs the government schools?
The teachers' unions do.
What is the most power...
35% of the delegates in
the Democratic Convention
are teachers' unions' members.
They run the Democratic party.
Unfortunately, too many Democrats
put the interest of the teachers'
unions ahead of the kids
that we have the schools that
are supposed to be served.
- All right, we literally only have five--
- No, no, I was just getting going here!
- I know, I know, we only
have five minutes left.
- I'm teasing.
- 'Cause you gotta get to Fox, it's okay.
- Next time I'm in LA, can
I come back on the show?
I'd love to keep talking to you.
- Yes, you can absolutely come back
and we'll do it with no time limit.
But in five minutes, this is
gonna be almost impossible,
can you give me a sorta basic breakdown
of where we're at with China?
I think this is pretty much
the most confusing thing right now.
People have no idea what is
being ramped up right now.
- So it's not just confusing,
this is the issue of our time.
I've called this the--
- Well, congratulations.
I've given you five minutes.
- Yeah, I know, it's the
epic battle of our time.
Just as from the 1950s
through the late '80s,
it was the Cold War with the Soviet Union,
now we have an epic battle,
I think this is the new
Cold War, I really do.
I think that this is World War
IV (chuckles) that we've got.
I mean, China is--
- Wait, why'd you skipped three there?
- Pardon me?
- Why'd you skip World War III?
- Well, I think you could say the Cold War
was sorta World War III.
- Oh, okay.
- But in any case, I mean,
I'm exaggerating a little bit,
but the point I'm making is,
China is becoming increasingly
a menace on the world scene.
The march towards freedom,
look, Mao was the single
greatest villain maybe who ever
walked on the planet earth.
I mean, he killed tens
and tens of millions
of his own people.
And then finally they
moved away from communism,
which we were talking about before,
and they started to embrace privatization
and free enterprise, not fully,
but they moved in that direction.
And they had a boom!
I mean, one of the great
booms ever in history
what happened in China
over the last 30 years.
The problem has been, they've moved more
in a Stalinistic direction now.
So they're building up their military,
they're cheating on trade deals,
they've never opened
up their markets to us.
The way I describe it to Donald Trump,
not that he needed any urging
on this, 'cause he got this,
we are in an abusive trade
relationship with China.
We've opened up our markets to them,
they have not opened
up their markets to us.
They're stealing our
intellectual property.
I applaud Trump for finally
calling them out on this.
It's about time.
Where this is right now,
the ball's in their court.
We have a mini deal right
now, but look, China could...
You can't trust these people
as far as you could spit.
I mean, the problem is they
also don't keep their word.
So it's a tricky situation,
but this is a battle
that's not gonna be resolved
in the next three months
or six months or a year or two.
It's probably gonna go
on for a decade or two,
and the big issue is, will
the United States or China
be the world economic superpower
over the next 25 or 30 years?
You know who I'm gonna put my money on?
Us.
- I think you're putting it on
the U.S.
- I'm putting it on us.
You know why?
'Cause we still do have
a free enterprise system.
They are command and control.
They have the Elizabeth
Warren type of economy.
It doesn't work.
- So you think ultimately that sorta thing
might work at some level
for some period of time,
but ultimately it creates that.
- It fails.
Show me any time, I would
say to my liberal friends,
show me any time, any place,
anywhere where that model has worked?
It didn't work for the Soviet Union,
it hasn't worked for North Korea,
it didn't work for Hugo
Chavez in Venezuela,
and it didn't work for Castro.
I mean, it's never worked anywhere,
because the genius of the
free enterprise system
is millions of actors who make decisions.
The idea that you can
have a few politicians
in a central politburo
that can make the decisions
about an economy with millions
and millions of decisions,
it's ludicrous, it will break down.
I'm putting my money on Silicon Valley
and the American--
- They've got their own
set of problems though because
of how lefty they've gone.
But that's a whole other topic
that we'll have to discuss next time.
I think you proved to
me you're an economist.
- Wait, one other big
advantage over China,
I always say this in my speeches,
our Chinese are smarter
than their Chinese.
(laughing)
- I think you proved to me
you're an economist here
because we probably got
the most amount of ideas
packed into the shortest
show I've ever done.
- It's called efficiency, my friend.
- That is efficiency, there you go.
You guys can follow Steve
@StephenMoore on Twitter,
and we will have him back
for a full episode soon enough.
All right, thanks.
If you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist,
all right over here.
And to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.